And I think as I get a little bit older,
then I start to get in touch with them more than I'm like,
Oh man,
I don't want to feelings.
How much of a big growth push was it for you to like get California being around
all those different kinds of people and be around the comedy store?
And I think intimidating is the biggest thing for me.
I don't want to bother people.
Yeah.
Sometimes it still is.
Like I'll talk to,
you know,
guys that I admire or stuff or look up to as comedians.
And sometimes I feel,
um,
I feel,
I don't know if I feel inferior,
but I just,
for some reason I always feel like,
you know,
I don't want people to think that I'm trying to take anything from them.
I know what you mean.
And so it makes me feel like I feel like that too.
Yeah.
It's like I'm afraid to ask sometimes or to tall or even to engage because I
just think that people are gonna think that I'm not trying to be genuine.
Yeah.
And so and if I don't know how I feel and how genuine I am sometimes or if I
questioned that,
if I question myself all the time,
then that makes that even double scary to try and like create friendships and
stuff.
I feel you,
I know exactly what you're saying but it's getting better.
I think,
you know,
there's been a lot of support like you know guys like you getting a hang out
with some of the other guys,
you know and just realize that we're all the same.
Yeah.
It just takes,
it takes a while to realize that.
I remember the same feeling I had,
especially in the 90s when my career could have gone any,
either way.
It could have crashed and burned.
Just as easy as it could have survived.
It didn't necessarily have to keep going and it'll all those,
those days when I'd run into people that were successful at see them and I just
feel weird.
Do you want to say hi to him?
Felt odd.
Yeah.
I met Dave Chappelle when he was like,
I think he was 18 and I was 21 or 22 or something like that.
How old's Dave now?
46 [inaudible] I think he's like four years younger than me.
So whatever that was.
So maybe he was 18 I was 44 44 so older than that.
So he must've been 18 and I must have been 24 so when,
when I met him,
you know,
we were both just starting out.
We were both kids,
but he got way more famous than me quick.
And I was more famous for doing other shit.
Like I was famous for a fear factor and for being on a,
on a sitcom,
you know,
it wasn't famous for being myself and so I'd be like weird around him too.
But he was always friendly.
They'll be like,
okay,
I guess.
I guess he actually likes me.
Yeah,
but this is that weird thing.
We,
it takes a while to be comfortable enough in your own skin,
where now I see people like whoever it is,
like I ranted a Patton Oswald last night,
gave him a big hug,
like,
what's up?
What are you doing?
I don't feel weird around him at all.
Right.
I don't feel reared around other famous comedians anymore.
I certainly did you,
but you always question your legitimacy question whether or not you should be
there,
you know,
questioned whether you're,
you're enough or whether they like you or maybe they don't like your kind of
comedy,
or maybe they don't like what you're doing or,
yeah.
Yeah.
There's a,
yeah.
There's so many questions.
There's so much in,
for me anyway.
Yeah.
There was some of,
there's just been so much in,
you know,
a feeling of,
just growing up,
feelings of self worth issues and then it,
man,
all that kind of stuff.
But I think it does get better.
Yeah.